même accueil
le rythme fou rire assuré ne plus de
confettis et de serpentins
lorsque filin qui fait pencher la
balance
attention
allez salut on va aller oui j'ai
toujours eu des chiens ma tendre enfance
je peux faire te raconter ma vie par mes
chiens sous le par mais un micro le
premier tient donc me souviens c'était
cora cora c'était un gros papillon blanc
parce qu'à l'époque c'était le tchad non
pas parce que bon c'est un chien de la
famille mais c'était avant tout le chien
ne va pas c'était son être et carette
est très amusant c'était en belgique
puisque je suis né en belgique c'était à
bruxelles est correct d'achat très
amusant parce que il était très joueurs
mais il ya quelque chose qui ne m'est
pas c'était les uniformes et très
souvent d'ailleurs il a marqué les
chiens n'aime pas les une forme maintenu
qu'il n'avait pas les bonnes soeurs et
les curés or nous habitions à côté d'un
couvent où moi j'étais à l'école
d'ailleurs à l'école des ursulines à
laquelle parce ça coûtait une fortune à
mon père parce que chaque fois que
sentel laisser sortir corps à crac'h put
une robe de bonnes soeurs et cac paris
fils anne-sophie seraient des accrocs
alors ça donne beaucoup d'éloges à tous
vous êtes plus touchées ou plutôt cher
moi je suis plutôt chien j'aime bien les
chats mais je suis plutôt chiant je
fiche ya lapin mais je suis moins
charruyer moi je vais vous dire j'ai un
j'ai envie d'avoir un chien pas pour moi
mais j'ai envie d'être quelque chose
pour le chien et les gens qui ont des
chiens pour se faire plaisir à eux pour
aller parader avec une oie moi c'est
pour le plaisir de pouvoir m'en occuper
voiliers vont avoir du mal à regarder ça
c'est adorable
à l'aide de chat de la maison yakiti
d'abord quidam lancé louis ii depuis
très très longtemps
ça va faire plus de dix ans c'est un
chien qui a été abandonnée c'est de dire
qu'on a trouvés ils avaient un collier
la veine numéro de téléphone et on a
téléphoné la femme nous a répondu tout
quand vous vous mêlez moi je vais plus
de ce chien c'est un chien fugueur
de quoi vous mêler à eux ni même quand
vous avez laissé votre téléphone est
parti ça fugueurs je n'en peux plus
faisant vous voulez alors on a requis
bien sûr et une autre qui qui est resté
ici chez nous de temps en temps ça fait
des fugues on le retrouvait à la place
de la gare à de bièvre mais comme les
gens connaissaient le titille le boucher
téléphoné dès en bernadette bernadette
les critiques il balade sur la place du
marché et revenaient mais maintenant il
est trop vieux et ne fait plus de fugue
du tout il se contente de faire des
grands trous dans dans le jardin
d'essayer de déraciner les arbustes et
de de chasse et parce que c'est les
quelques chansons aux chasseurs quand tu
as perdu en l'appeler perdu merkel a
trouvé tout simplement il a il a une
histoire parce qu'avant perdu j'avais un
autre chien qui s'appelle qui s'appelait
gaspard est bon gaspard est mort et
quelques jours après sur entre à la
maison il y avait un gros chien devant
ma porte
une nuit des gars là je suis rentré j'ai
un gros chien noir marpent jeudi le
va-t-en ou chien va t'en va t'en
pas moyen de faire des cas nier devant
le portail
j'attends et je blague le sont leurs
entrées lalani en dentelle et faudra
commissariat voir si les gens vous
paraître la musique leur chien
le lendemain on a téléphoné au
commissariat personne n'avait réclament
une chaire alors je suppose que ce sont
des gens qui sont partis en vacances
c'était comment c'était au mois de
juillet qui ont sorti le chien qui
commit devant devant portail et ben il
n'y est plus jamais sortie de dc quoi
est toujours là veni tour que c'est
l'âme de moments de mon chien gaspard
qui revenu dans d'interdits bien qu à
bon prix un premier plan et à la paire
dit pourquoi pensez-vous que les animaux
de compagnie apporte je veux qu'elles
touchent moins spécieux je crois que ça
apporte surtout à des gens d'abord qui
n'ont peut-être pas d'enfant ça amène
beaucoup et puis les gens les gens seuls
aussi parce que moi je connais un
monsieur qui a perdu sa femme n'y a pas
longtemps tu vas tout ce qui lui reste
son chien est cet homme est fou de ce
chien je souhaiterais près ce que qui
meurt avant son chien car il va être
tellement malheureux il a été tellement
marre de perdre sa femme et sera comme
beaucoup plus malheureux qui perdra tu
n'auras plus rien s'il leur a des amis
mais les amis on n'a pas tellement fait
alors voilà c'est terminé
les gens voulaient pas moins de ce chien
c'est bruno c'est mon mari qui me
l'acheter c'est je faisais un gala à la
salle pleyel il ya de ça quelques mois
est une jeune femme qui veut me faire
signer un autographe et dans les bras
elle avait un tout petit chien miniature
comme ça son astuce pizza et bruno des
eaux qu'il est beau ce petit chien on
ferait un petit chemin à jouer des
parties à rochefort et de la rochelle et
marne et ce chien
moi je vois ni la chance à l'époque
j'étais en tournée à limoges et m'a
ramené cette petite boule c'était comme
ça je veux dire quand il est fait et les
mouiller on dirait un saucisson a
bataillé comprends rien du tout et pour
vous qu'est-ce qui compte fidèlement le
plus dans la vie c'est l'humour la
drôlerie où la tendresse et la tendresse
c'est la tendresse et la drôlerie en âne
à la drôlerie l'humour j'aime beaucoup
mais j'entrevois avec mes copains de de
théâtre et des variétés ou avec les gens
que je rencontre car en fait je dois
dire que j'ai un besoin de données a
besoin de partager avec les gens et ça
je trouve chaque soir en fait je partage
avec mon public je parle avec plein tous
les clients qui sont là et ça sent que
les grands pays
d'abord moi je réagis pas comme une
adulte parce que je trouve les adultes
surtout trop sérieux ils sont pas
seulement celui très bien avec les
enfants
comme je suis bien acquise animaux